SPEAKER 1: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
morning everybody.
Today we're going to
continue our journey
in looking at the 10 sort
of basic types of reactions
that you will encounter when
studying basic metabolism.
And they're all found
on your vitamin bottle.
So here are the
Flintstones vitamins.
I like Flintstones
vitamins because you
don't have to swallow them.
You can chew them.
And today what I'm going
to start talking about
is redox chemistry.
What are the two redox
active cofactors?
And what we will
focus on today is
vitamin B2, which is riboflavin,
and vitamin B3 which is niacin.
So we're going to talk about
oxidation and reduction.
And what the cofactors
are that involved
in these transformations in
all primary metabolic pathways.
So the first thing I want
to do is introduce you
to these two cofactors, the
structure of the cofactors.
Then what I'll do is focus on a
comparison of their properties.
And then I want to
focus on the mechanism
of how these cofactors work.
And once you master
these concepts,
you really will encounter
them over and over again
throughout your
journey in metabolism.
And you'll be familiar
with the kinds
of chemical transformations
that are occurring.
So the first cofactor
comes from niacin.
And it is nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide
in the reduced state.
Or nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide
in the oxidized state.
And as with all
cofactors, the vitamins
are a precursor to
the cofactor, and they
have to be converted
inside the cell
to the active form
of the cofactor.
So if you look at NADH-- let
me draw that structure for you,
and then I'm going to show you
that while the structure is
quite complex, most of it is
not volved in the chemical
transformations.
And so we'll put a big R
group on most of the cofactor.
And you don't have to
memorize the structures of any
of these cofactors.
And that you will be given
the structures whenever
you have any kind of
exercise to carry out.
So the form of the vitamin is
actually a nicotinamide ring.
And then it needs
to be metabolized
to the structure I'm
drawing now which
has the nicotinamide
ring attached
to a ribose ring, which is then
attached to ADP, which you're
all familiar with.
And I'm just going to
abbreviate the adenosine part
of a molecule with an AD.
So this part of
the molecule we're
going to call for the rest
of this exercise today
the R group, because it's not
involved in the chemistry.
And really, all of
the chemistry happens
in this part of the molecule.
This is the business end,
and this is the reduced form
of the cofactor, NADH.
So in addition to
the reduced form,
since we're doing
oxidation and reduction,
you need to know what
the oxidized form is.
And the oxidized
form is the following
where you need to lose
a couple of electrons
and a couple of protons
out of this ring
to generate this
nicotinamide ring.
And again, this part of the
molecule is indicated as R,
and then you retain
a positive charge.
So again, this is the
part of the molecule
we're going to be focusing on.
And this is the oxidized
form of the cofactor.
So what I want to
do now is show you
how this compares to the second
form of the organic cofactor
that you encounter over and
over again in metabolism.
And this is FADH2, or FMNH2.
And that's the reduced
form, versus FAD or FMN.
So this is one of
the most complicated
of all the cofactors.
And you'll see that it
has a very complex ring
structure called an
isoalloxazine ring-- which
I'm drawing now--
that most of you
have likely never
encountered before.
And when you look at the
structure of this molecule,
you probably will have
no idea about where
the chemical reactivity is.
And I'll show you where
the chemical reactivity is
and how we know that
in a few minutes.
So attached to this
nitrogen is more complex
structure with a sugar
where x can be phosphate.
This is called the
flavinmanonucleotide, reduced.
This is the reduced form.
And if x is equal to ADP, this
is flavinadninedineucleotide
reduce.
And I want to point out that
ADP is present in both NADH
and FADH2, as it is present
actually, in coenzyme A
and in ATP.
So ADP plays a central role
in almost all the chemical
transformations,
the 10 reactions
we actually talk about
that are central to all
of primary metabolism.
However in this case, again,
this part of the molecule
we're going to call R, is not
involved in the chemistry.
So the business end of the
molecule is indicated here.
And so this is the business end,
in this is the reduced state.
So this cofactor has
to be able to toggle
between the reduced state
and the oxidized state.
And if you look at
the oxidized state--
so I'm going to indicate this
whole part of the molecule
is R-- you could see
a change in this part
of the isoalloxazine ring.
That is you've lost two
protons and two electrons
to form the oxidized
form of this cofactor.
Now I also want to give
you the nomenclature
for the isoalloxazine
ring because I'm
going to tell you where
the chemical reactive
positions are.
And so you need to know
the numbering of the ring.
And so this is the N1
position, this is 2, 3, 4.
This carbon between these two
positions is called the C4A.
This is carbon C4.
And this is the N5 position.
And we'll see that C4
and N5 become important
in the overall chemistry
of the transformation.
So these are the two cofactors.
Again, this one is considerably
more complex than this one.
But what I want
to do, and you'll
see both of these cofactors used
over and over again in break
down or biosynthesis.
The sugars breakdown or
biosynthesis of fatty acids.
The question is
when are they used
and what is the distinction
between these cofactors?
So what I want to do is compare
the properties of these two
cofactors and then
specifically give you
an example of how each
of these cofactors work.
So on one side
I'll have NAD/NADH,
and the other side will have
FAD, again, the oxidized form,
and FADH2, the reduced form.
So we have NAD/NADH FAD/FADH2.
And I want to compare
these two cofactors.
And the first thing I want
to compare is the chemistry.
And what we will see
is NAD/NADH always
does 2 electron chemistry
all of the time.
On the other hand, FAD/FADH2 can
do either 1 electron chemistry
or 2 electron chemistry.
And in fact, function of
flavins inside the cell
is the major mediator
between something
that can donate 2 electrons
and can something that can
accept only a single electron.
So something they could
donate 2 electrons
would be NAD/NADH, which
I'll show you in a minute,
and something that can accept
only a single electron,
or like metals.
Like, if you think
back to hemoglobin,
and you think about the ion 3
state going to the ion 2 state.
So there's a big
distinction between the two.
The second thing is since were
doing oxidation and reduction,
we need to think about
the reduction potentials.
And if you think
about the reduction
potential of NAD NADH, it turns
out to be minus 320 millivolts.
And what you need to recall
from freshman chemistry
is that the more
positive the number,
the easier it is to reduce.
So the fact that this
is minus 320 millivolts
tells you that NAD likes to be
in the oxidized state, the NAD
state.
On the other hand,
FAD/FADH2 can vary
between minus 450 millivolts
to plus 150 millivolts.
So this is a huge difference
in reduction potential,
600 millivolts.
So why is that true?
It turns out that if
you look at the hundreds
of enzyme structures
that we now have-- we've
gone through a structural
revolution in the last 15
years-- all of the structures
where NAD/NADH bind are
homologous to each other.
And in fact, these
structures don't
have anything designed into
the structure where they
perturb the redox potential.
The redox potential
remains the same,
regardless of what enzyme
time it's bound to.
On the other hand,
flavins don't maintain
a single type of binding site.
They have five or six different
kinds of binding sites.
And that's because
the flavin chemistry,
as you can see from this
isoalloxazine ring I introduced
to you just a minute ago, does
much more diverse chemistry.
And in fact, the active site
can tune the redox potential
so it facilitates
either 2 electron
chemistry or 1
electron chemistry
or a combination of the two.
So the next thing that's
really important in thinking
about the two cofactors
and their differences
is that NAD/NADH can
act as a substrate.
That is, NAD/NADH is
any D, for example
would act as an oxidant
of some second substrate.
Every time you have
an oxidant, you
have to have something
that's going to be oxidized.
And during turn over of
oxidized reduced states,
the substrates and products
must come on and off the enzyme.
So they dissociate in
every single turn over.
FAD/FADH2 on the
other hand, is always
tightly bound or covalently
bound to the substrate.
And so that means that if
FAD gets reduced to FADH2,
it doesn't disassociate.
So you need to have a way in
the active site of the enzyme
where the FADH2
can be reoxidized.
And again, that's quite
distinct from NAD/NADH.
The fourth thing I want to
talk about just briefly--
and this is what
I'm going to focus
the rest of this
little section on--
is the mechanisms by which
these cofactors work.
And so out of all
of the cofactors
you're going to be introduced
to in this little this section
in general on the
10 basic reactions,
this is probably the simplest.
And NAD/NADH involves hydride
transfer and proton transfer.
So hydride is a hydrogen with a
pair of electrons and a proton.
And we'll see that in a minute.
With FAD/FADH2 the chemistry is
considerably more complicated.
But what I will show
you is that it can also
do hydride transfer.
And when it does
hydride transfer,
it does it to the N5 position.
So if we go back for
a second and look
at the flavin in
the nomenclature,
this is the N5 position.
I also pointed out you can
do C4A chemistry, which
is in your lexicon,
but we're not
going to discuss further today.
So you can do N5 chemistry
by hydride transfer.
And you can also
do C4A chemistry,
which you will see
later on when you
start talking about
primary metabolic pathways.
So what I want to do now is
focus on a specific example
and show you what the
basic chemistry is
with these two systems
focusing on hydride transfer
of chemistry.
So an example I've
chosen to briefly look at
is what I would call an ending
to the glycolysis pathway.
Glycolosis, as you
already know, is
breakdown of sugar under
anaerobic conditions.
So under aerobic
conditions, what
happens is when all
this energy is given off
when you break down
your sugar, it's
stored in chemical bonds, NADH.
The NADH then goes into
the respiratory chain.
And the respiratory
chain ultimately
transfers this energy
to convert oxygen
into water, which
is really releases
a huge amount of
energy, which is then
trapped to make the energy
currency of the cell, ATP.
So we're under
anaerobic conditions.
And we need to be able
to recycle and keep.
Because the NAD/NADH
comes off and on
the enzyme at every
single turnover,
you really need to be able to
recycle the reduced form back
to the oxidized form.
So glycolysis can
actually continue.
So what happens at the
ending, one anaerobic ending
of glycolysis, is you
need a proton plus NADH,
so that's the
reduced form that's
generated during glycolosis,
plus the molecule called
pyruvate.
This is a molecule you're going
to see over and over again
over the course of the
semester whose structure you
need to remember.
So this is the reduced state
and this is the oxidized state.
And NADH is going to reduce
this ketone to an alcohol.
And it itself becomes oxidized.
NADH loses a hydron and
a proton to form NAD,
and you generate
lactic acid where
this hydrogen from
the NAD as a hydride
is going to get transferred
to the carbon of the carbonyl.
And this proton in some
way comes from solution,
and has picked up a proton from
the active site of the enzyme.
Now another point
I wanted to make,
which you will encounter again
over the course of thinking
about coupling
reactions in metabolism
to make them favorable, is
that with NAD/NADH cofactor,
you always have to
think about the proton.
So you need a proton to
have a balanced equation.
That means that if you're
at pH 6 versus pH 8,
the concentration of the
species changes dramatically.
And that can affect
where the equilibrium
of the overall reaction lies.
So you need to keep in the
back of your mind there's
a proton with NAD/NADH systems.
And so this is NAD,
but it turns out
that flavins can also catalyze
the same type of reaction.
So in the case of this
particular enzyme,
it's found in
eukaryotic systems,
it's found also in
prokaryotic systems.
But in the case of the
flavin dependent enzymes,
it's only found in
bacterial systems.
And so their reaction goes
more favorably in the direction
I'm writing it now,
but again, it's
an equilibrium reaction where
you take lactate-- so this
is now the reduced state.
And so you now have FMN.
So this is the form
of the cofactor that's
used with this specific
enzyme, but the chemistry
is same with FMN and FAD.
And so this needs
to get oxidized.
And it gets oxidized
to form pyruvate.
And the FMN gets
reduced to form FMNH2.
So both of these are capable
of catalyzing the same redox
chemistry.
And this is consistent
with what I've
told you before about
the redox potential.
So NAD/NADH is always
in this region.
But you can see
that FAD/FADH2 also
covers that region as well.
So many of the chemistries
between these two cofactors
can be overlapping.
And you'll see this in for
example, fatty acid oxidation
and fatty acid biosynthesis.
And it really is not clear
at all which one of the redox
chemistry you could use.
Nature, in fact could
use different cofactors
in different organisms.
But we know what the
cofactors are in human systems
because we purified
all the enzymes
and study the
cofactor requirements.
So this is the reaction
I want to focus on.
And what I forgot to
tell you to maybe make
this more relevant
to some of you
I guess, since this is
what you do when you go
to college nowadays, is most
of you have heard about yeast,
that under anaerobic
conditions make you a friend,
to make you happy
and cheery when
you're having
tough times at MIT,
you want to drink some ethanol.
Yeast are able to
convert glucose
all the way down under anaerobic
conditions into ethanol,
and in fact uses the cofactor
NADH to in two steps,
convert pyruvate into a
molecule called acid aldehyde.
And then the NADH
converts the acid aldehyde
into ethanol, which is the major
ingredient of beer and wine.
So what I want to do
now is very briefly then
focus on the chemistry of
how NADH actually works.
So if we're now going to
look at the chemistry of this
and the mechanism, let's
start with pyruvate.
And you need to go
back and you need
to think about the
carbonyl chemistry you've
been introduced to when talking
about the claisen reaction
and the aldol reaction.
And we spent a lot of
time on carbonyl chemistry
because it's central to
everything in biochemistry.
And so you remember
that a carbonyl
is polarized where the electrons
like to result on the oxygen,
leaving a deficiency
of electrons
on the carbon of the carbonyl.
And so one can draw
a resonant structure.
This is the
predominate structure,
but these resonance structures
often tell you something
about where the molecule
is most reactive.
And so what we've done is
oxygen is electro negative
and likes to can accommodate
electrons in its orbitals.
So it forms a
resonance structure
like this leaving behind
electron deficiency
at the carbon.
And so we want to reduce
this carbonyl to an alcohol.
And this is done with the
reduced form of the cofactor.
So again, in every
redox chemistry,
this is the oxidized form,
this is the reduced form.
And so now the question is,
how does this chemistry happen?
So let me point
out here-- and this
is something you will hear
about over and over again
in basic metabolism-- but
these two hydrogens-- and this
is the 1, 2, 3, 4 position of
the nicotinamide ring are not
equivalent.
And why aren't they equivalent?
They're not equivalent
because all of the chemistry
happens in the active site
of an enzyme that is chiral.
So these hydrogens
are prochiral.
And because they sit in
a chiral environment,
that makes these hydrogens
act like they're chiral.
So all chemistry with
NADH is stereo specific.
Depending on the active site,
only one of these two protons
is involved in hydride transfer.
So if you look at
the chemistry now,
we're set up to deliver a
proton with a pair of electrons,
that's a hydride, to this
carbon of the carbonyl.
See we have a hydride transfer.
And now we have the electron
density sitting on the oxygen.
And so likely then in the
active site of the enzyme
you have a general
acid catalyst which is
able to then donate a proton.
And remember I told
you that NAD/NADH
involves hydride transfer
and proton transfer.
So what you generate
then is OH, where
this hydrogen comes from
a general acid catalyst
in the active site.
And you have the hydride
transfer coming from the NADH
to generate lactic acid.
And now what you've generated
is the oxidized form of the NAD.
So reduced form oxidized,
reduced form oxidized.
So this is the general reaction
and all NAD/NADH enzymes
involves this simple type of
[INAUDIBLE], protons, hydrides,
and protons.
Now what I want
to do is show you
one of the many
types of reactions
that flavins can undergo.
And again we're focusing on
hydride transfer reactions.
And a recall for you
that again, the redox
potentials of the flavins
in the NAD/NADH overlap.
So this is always minus 320.
But this has a span
of redox potentials.
And in fact, what
you will see when
you look at basic metabolism is
often FAD is reduced by NADH.
And so these two partner
up to do chemistry.
And so what I want to do now
is show you the chemistry
with the flavin and NADH.
If we go back and we look at
our oxidized form of the flavin,
and again, I'm not going to
draw out all the structure.
And remember there's
a lot of spinach here
and there's also
some spinach here.
This is the business
end of the molecule.
And remember I told you the
business end of the molecule
is the N5 and the C4A position.
And so now we have our NAD.
NADH, sorry.
So this is the oxidized form,
this is the reduced form.
And so NAD/NADH goes through
a hydride proton transfers,
does it stereo specifically.
And the question is,
where does the chemistry
happen with the flavin?
And the chemistry happens
at stereo specifically.
So each enzyme
will be different.
You can figure out what
the stereo chemistry
is at the N5 position.
So here is again,
the N5 position.
So you have hydride
transfer to the N5 position.
And now you can pick up a
proton or not at this position.
I'm going to show you the PKA.
If you go back and you look
at the handout in the lexicon,
you'll see the PKA
of this nitrogen
is under physiological
conditions, about 7.
So it can be proteinated
or not proteinated.
And so what then happens is you
end up with the reduced form
where this hydrogen is
transferred to the N5 position,
and you could pick up a hydrogen
here, from AH leaving you
with A. So this proton,
this may or may not
be proteinated depending on
the active site of the enzyme.
And so then what
you also have here
is the oxidized form of NADH.
Now those of you who
were paying attention
to what I was just saying
with the reduction of pyruvate
to lactate, I just went
through this whole big spiel
about how you wanted to
take advantage of the fact
that carbonyl is a polarized
delta plus delta minus,
and that the nucleophile,
this case the hydride,
is always being transferred to
the electron deficient carbon,
not to the oxygen that already
has a lot of electron density.
So you might be
asking yourself well,
why doesn't that hydride get
transferred to this position?
This is a position,
if you look at this,
and you take it out of context
of the isoalloxazine ring.
This looks remarkably
similar to this carbonyl.
And in fact, this is where your
chemical intuition falls apart.
And you need to
know that you don't
have chemical intuition
about those people that
spent 40 years studying
isoalloxazine rings.
And this is a complex
heterocyclical molecule
where I think most
chemists, when
looking at this
for the first time,
had no clue as to what the
reactive positions were
and what the chemistry was.
And they spent, in
the 1970s and 1980s,
spent a decade figuring out
the chemistry of flavins.
And so I'm telling you
what the answer is.
There is experimental
evidence that supports this
that in the case
of NADH, hydride
is transferred to
the N5 position
to give you the reduced form
and the oxidized form of NAD.
So I hope I've
gotten you excited
interested about the two redox
active cofactors that you're
going to encounter over and
over again during your journey
through primary metabolic
pathways, FAD and NAD.
And I hope I've
taught you something
about the chemistry of how
these two cofactors work
and you'll get
plenty of practice
with these cofactors over
the rest of the semester.